everything we do at hillsdale college is
guided by the founding documents of the
college
written in the 1840s and 1850s at a time
of growing crisis in the country
the founders of hillsdale college were
grateful to god
for the inestimable blessings of civil
and religious liberty
and intelligent piety in the land and
they created the college
to promulgate and protect those
blessings
today we are faced with a new crisis but
we can learn from our founders example
with gratitude to god for the liberty we
have left
we stand now firmly in opposition to the
administrative state that seeks to will
power
all the powers of government and change
human nature
this regime also seeks as we have seen
in the last few weeks to punish its
opponents
and sweep away any semblance of american
republicanism
or western classical thought now they
say
we are to move forward with historical
progress
be good global citizens and accept the
decisions of our ruling elites
at a time when our rights have been
openly abrogated in the name of public
health
it is important to figure out what is
truly dangerous and what is not
hence this evening we are delighted to
hear from an expert on the subject of
the current administration's turn to bad
foreign policy
which could further endanger our rights
as american citizens
but expertise is not good enough as we
know in fact as many of you
here know expertise can be a hindrance
to good education and good thinking in
general
he who seeks to educate his fellow
citizens properly
must also be prudent and wise
our speaker tonight possesses such
virtues
michael duran is a senior fellow at the
hudson institute where he specializes in
middle east security issues
he received his ba from stanford
university and his ma and phd from
princeton university
i think that's the second and third best
colleges behind hillsdale
they're moving down on the list every
day so uh
he's also a senior fellow at the hudson
institute where
excuse me there's copied twice there
he served he also served in the george w
bush administration as a senior director
in the national
security council with responsibility for
the entire middle east
except iraq a former senior fellow at
the brookings institution
dr duran has taught at nyu princeton and
the university of central florida
he has written for numerous publications
including the wall street journal
the new york times the new york post usa
today
and the los angeles times he's the
author of three books
including pan-arabism before nasser
egyptian power politics and the
palestinian question
and ike's gamble america's rise to
dominance in the middle east
please join me in welcoming dr duran
well uh thanks to all of you for coming
and thanks matt for that introduction
i spoke uh i was like last year i guess
at
hillsdale and i i forgot how much i
appreciated matt's
ironic sense of humor but then
matt also said that i think you said
that i have
possessed the prudence and wisdom but
remember he's also very ironic
so anyway it's a great pleasure to be
here
oh look at that it bounces do you see
that
it's kind of cool it's a great pleasure
to be here
and i'm going to talk to you about the
biden administration's iran policy
let me start out by just saying that
we all know we live in a polarized age
right now
in our politics and increasingly our
foreign policy debate
is becoming uh part of our domestic
debate
in fact the national security advisor
jake sullivan said uh just a few
few months ago that we live in an age
when domestic politics is foreign policy
and foreign policy is domestic politics
i think uh that's true in general but
it's especially true with regard to the
iran question and that's uh
that's true for a lot of reasons but one
reason is that the iran question is very
much tied to the israel question and as
we all know
israel has become a very partisan issue
in our
uh in our politics there are now
i think two pretty clear conceptions
about how to deal with iran and i'm
going to call them
for the sake of discussion the the the
democratic position and the republican
position
uh but that's a little bit it's a little
bit crude
uh because if you if you look at this
closely
or if you follow closely the way i have
you know that there
are actually um a fair
number of uh republican foreign policy
experts that are actually very
sympathetic to the
democratic what i'm calling the
democratic conception
and even a few democrats who are
um who are more sympathetic to the re to
the republican
view but the the the center of gravity
on either side
pulls them apart so i think it's it
makes sense as sort of ideal types to
say
democratic and republican let me let me
start with the republican view
uh actually before i do that let me just
say
there is a continuity running
uh between them uh a a continuity of
intention
i would say uh they're they're seeking i
think to
uh the the two different conceptions are
seeking to
achieve the same goal and that goal is
that to pull the united states back from
the middle east
three presidents have uh have been
elected
in a row from different parties very
different conceptions
who agree that we don't want to have
another major
war in the in the middle east we don't
want large numbers of american troops
uh on the ground in the middle east so
we're going to pull back that's going to
create something of a vacuum
how do we how do we but we need to
remain
engaged in in the region i think
if there's not a consensus there's still
a sense
there has been a sense among the all of
the last three presidents that we have
to remain engaged
to some extent we don't want our enemies
to completely fill the vacuum
and so how do we stabilize the region
and pull back at the same time
and that's what these two conceptions
two different conceptions
are meant to uh to achieve stabilize the
region
while we pull back from it um the
republican
answer is that uh
it is that iran is the primary threat to
the united states
to the u.s order on the ground in
in the region and iran is working
if not necessarily in an alliance at
least in an alignment
with china and russia with the intention
of weakening
weakening the american order
expelling the united states eventually
from the region
and weakening america's uh america's
allies
so the republican answer is we we build
up
a coalition of uh
of allies on the ground as we pull back
we build up our allies
and we and we create a coalition
designed to achieve two major goals
first
to prevent iran from getting a nuclear
weapon
and number two to uh to contain iran
on the ground especially in places like
iraq syria lebanon
and and and yemen so
multilateral containment and then we saw
in the trump administration combined
with
massive economic sanctions designed to
contain
weaken and then also prevent it from
getting
a nuclear weapon the democratic
conception is
based on a radically different
understanding
of iran these are these are two
different concepts of what iran
is and they are they are basically
irreconcilable the the republican
assumption
is that iran is a hegemon it has
hegemonic aspirations
yes it's weak yes it's weak
i think everyone every expert on iran
now recognizes that the regime
has less support inside iran than ever
than ever before its basis support is
very narrow uh
yet it still has in the republican
conception
an aspiration to expel the united states
if not from the persian
if not from the entire middle east at
least from the uh from the persian gulf
and to weaken its allies and it has
developed
techniques i call it the hezbollah model
of building up
uh building up proxies on the ground and
distributing to it
precision guided weaponry techniques
that are very
effective at undermining america and its
allies
in a in an asymmetric uh in an
asymmetric fashion
uh it is inveterately
hostile to the united states
uh and to its and to its order the
democratic conception
of iran is radically different iran
in the democratic view is
a defensive power it the the regime
wants to stand
wants to stay in power in iran yes and
it's sitting on a volcano it knows it's
sitting on a volcano
it feels threatened by the united states
and
and its allies because of the aggressive
actions that the united states and its
allies
are habitually taking toward it
if the u.s and and and its allies
would offer a hand
in not necessarily friendship but at
least
in uh in an effort to seek
a diplomatic solution to the major
conflicts between them
between us it would find a potential
partner on the other side of uh
if not a partner a an actor with whom it
could reach
accommodations that would serve the the
american interest
there is in this view a significant
overlap in uh in interests
between the united states and and the
iranians
for example this is this is the
democratic view
not mine not my view uh the united
states
and iran share an interest in
stabilizing iraq
the iranians are not especially
interested
in projecting power into yemen they have
been
they have been drawn into into yemen
because of
unwise policies by especially america's
ally
saudi arabia they're not necessarily
seeking to in to entrench themselves in
syria
we could find an accommodation with the
um
with them if we work together with the
russians
uh you know in if we negotiate with the
russians and with the iranians
about the to limit the uh most
threatening aspects of iranian behavior
in syria
um and and and so on and so forth
basically
diplomatic engagement if carried out
um you know in a way that does not
threaten the regime in tehran
could lead to all kinds of benefits they
we we share a hostility to
radical supposedly to uh radical sunni
extremism groups like
isis and and and uh and al-qaeda so
all of this can be unlocked if we will
engage iran
diplomatically now the the the the
the democratic view then says well
what's the biggest
impediment to unlocking this [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
this the benefits of these shared
interests
the conflict over the iranian nuclear
program
so if we can first come to an agreement
on the nuclear program and put that off
to one side
then we can unlock this larger potential
for
strategic accommodation with the
iranians and
of course when it comes to the nuclear
program the republican view
says that iran is
iran is hell bent on acquiring a nuclear
weapon the evidence is overwhelming
that this is what they want look at the
price they have paid to keep a hold of
this
of this program we can't actually solve
that
we can't actually solve that problem
until we
rest the nuclear program from the talons
of the of the regime so those are the uh
those are the those are the two
conceptions
and uh uh i think it's very obvious
um if you've followed what what the
biden administration has done
since it came in that it is a
complete believer in what i'm calling
the democratic view
the democratic view was developed by
barack obama and his team
joe biden has this the same team and he
is seeking
to complete what obama started
and when when when you hear that phrase
complete what obama started the first
thing you think
is the jcpoa the nuclear deal he's
seeking to go back to the nuclear deal
but actually the concept is much larger
it's what i described to you
a a strategic accommodation with iran
across the board
the goal the goal is to solve
the the the goal is to stabilize
the middle east so the united states can
pull back from it
and the problem is in the in the
democratic view
that america's allies in particular the
israelis
and the saudis are acting like a
catapult that is throwing the united
states at
iran so what the a
inappropriate strategy is to pull the
united states away from its allies
first cut a deal with the iran on the
nuclear question
and then work with iran to stabilize
to yemen iraq syria
and and lebanon now
let me go through some components of
this i
i think our title hasn't hidden from
anyone the fact that
uh i am a complete believer in
the republican uh concept of how to do
this
and a um and a total disbeliever in all
of the assumptions of the uh
um uh of the of the democratic view
uh let me start with the uh with the
jcpoa
and some misconceptions about it
now it's politically
uh indefensible in american
in the american domestic arena outside
of the progressives
it's indefensible to say the united
states and iran
share a lot of interests we should be
working to reach an accommodation with
iran
and our allies israel and saudi arabia
are the problem
now the this is this is said in
progressive circles and i can uh
point you to articles by senior
officials in the
uh in the biden administration that
either say it outright or
make it clear that that's what they
think without actually saying it but you
can't stand up in congress and say that
and joe biden won't ever give a speech
a speech saying that so they have
developed the blind demonstration has
developed a rhetoric
that says that the goal of their policy
is to contain
iran but when you actually follow what
they're doing on the ground or in in
particular as you see that
to contain iran and to prevent it from
getting a nuclear weapon
but when you actually see what they're
doing their their their policies cannot
possibly achieve
the goals that they are claiming
they are claiming to to hold
so you either have to conclude that they
are deluded
and confused or they're dishonest
uh or perhaps disingenuous is a is a
better word
um and i think these are very smart
people uh
who are uh running the administration uh
tony blinken jake sullivan and so forth
this
national security adviser jake sullivan
anthony blinken the
secretary of state they know exactly
what they're doing
and they know why they're saying the
things that they're saying
and the first thing that they know is
that the jcpoa
will not stop iran from getting a
nuclear weapon
uh it's it's simply not possible we
don't need to go through all the
all the reasons why um why that's the
case there are many
but the simplest way to make the point
is that
the jcpoa contains within it what we
call the sunset
clauses the restrictions that the
the restrictions that the agreement
places on the iranian nuclear program
they evaporate over time by 2031
they're all gone all meaningful um all
meaningful restrictions on the nuclear
program
end by 2031. many of them end even
before 20
2031. some of them have already uh some
of them have
already ended um you cannot possibly
lift all the sanctions by 2031 and
prevent iran from getting a nuclear
weapon by 2031
iran will have an uh nuclear
enrichment and reprocessing program of
an industrial scale and it will have
an international
[Music]
legal stamp of approval
for that for that program so
as i say i could go through many other
aspects
of the of the program which show you
of the jcpoa which show you that it
cannot possibly
prevent them from having a nuclear
weapon but what it can do is what i
suggested before
it can park it can park the nuclear
program the
or it can park the controversy over the
nuclear program
off to one side while also
creating diplomatic channels with iran
in order to start this process of uh
of coming to a strategic accommodation
with the iranians over
other parts of the the region which is
the goal
the goal is to turn iran into a partner
of sorts
for for the united states based on this
understanding that there are these
shared interests
which which the experts know exists but
we can't talk about publicly because
it's politically unacceptable
uh in in the u.s
the other the other thing that the that
this program
that this policy will not do is it will
not contain iran
on the ground it won't contain the
militias
that iran is arming training and
equipping
and equipping with precision guided
weaponry
that is becoming ever more sophisticated
and the proof of that is again in the
jcpoa
because the jcpoa and the administration
is openly dishonest about this and i'll
say dishonest and not disingenuous
the jcpoa lifts all sanctions
on iran all meaningful sanctions
on on on iran and so
it gives iran the financial resources
the economic resources in order to build
up its
uh its militias and the and the
uh the administration wants to reduce
the american military footprint further
in the region
and it wants to do so in in its open
about this
in with diplomatic engagement of of iran
so the policy ends up being
a legitimation of iran's
positions the militia positions it has
built up in iraq
yemen and so forth again you see this
very clearly
in the way the united the united states
the biden administration treated saudi
arabia
when it came into office it immediately
launched a launched a campaign
against uh a moral campaign against
saudi arabia in general
but specifically with respect to yemen
lifting the sanctions on the houthis who
are the proxy of the iranians and
uh in yemen and claiming that by doing
so
we were going to create conditions that
would allow us to to solve the conflict
in
uh in yemen uh and putting enormous
pressure on saudi arabia
to to pull out of uh of yemen so
it the policy amounts to a de facto
recognition of the iranian position in
yemen
while delegitimating the saudi uh
the the the saudi position in yemen
and blaming the war and the humanitarian
and the humanitarian problems in
in yemen entirely on the saudis without
ever mentioning the iranian role
whatsoever the the administration has
developed the whole
rhetoric that avoids discussing iran at
all
in in the context of of yemen and always
talking in absolute moral terms about
yemen how we need to stop the war
uh in the killing and and so forth while
while blaming the the the saudis so what
this amounts to
what this ends up being then is uh
is a very significant realignment
of the united states away from
traditional allies
and toward the iranians so we're kind of
occupying a middle position now
no longer the united states is no longer
a under the mine demonstration
is no longer the leader of a coalition
designed to contain
iran and its great power supporters
china and and russia it's now taking up
a middle position
between its allies on the one hand and
the iranians on the other
recognizing the iranian position in a
number of key
areas while say while redefining the
role of the u.s support for allies
as support for their sovereign territory
so we will give you
resources to defend yourself against
uh iranian and proxies when they attack
you directly
but we will not support you in your
when you go beyond the the your borders
into places like yemen or
or syria to fight the uh the iranians
in the case of the saudis the mind
administration came down on them hard
right at the beginning and now you've
already seen the the ship in saudi
policy
there was a a couple of months ago a
very well publicized interview on saudi
television by
muhammad bin salman the crown prince of
saudi arabia the de facto ruler
where he said i'm starting a dialogue
with iran
i want to see a successful iran we want
we have friendly
feelings toward iran and so forth these
are not the deep
seated feelings that mohammed bin salman
has in his heart
toward iran this is a capitulation to
the biden administration by
uh by by the saudis there's something
similar going on in israel today
israel is in an analogous situation to
saudi arabia but its position is
somewhat different because
the united states cannot cannot come
directly at the israelis with the kind
of moral critique
that it has come that is directed at the
saudis
because israel's popular among key
constituencies even within the
democratic party
uh israel is popular and so
the the my demonstration has to come at
israel with more of a bank shot
but the change of government in israel
has made it easier for them to do that
and the
uh the new the lapid or bennett lapid
i say lapid because i don't know how
closely you're following all this but
former prime minister netanyahu calls it
the lapid government
because the prime minister has been it
but bennett is in
in the eyes of netanyahu he's a
right-wing traitor
who's moved he's now legitimate he's now
um uh helped the left wing and israel to
come to power
and he's given the the the the
government a right-wing face
uh and so uh netanyahu calls it the
laped government instead of the bennett
government
so i find it funny it's real
it's really funny it's a really funny
joke
anyway the uh uh the
the i i fall into habit of calling it
the lapid government myself
the the the bennett the bennett
government
is saying that now um
that the
netanyahu government got too
close to the republicans in washington
made israel a political football
in american politics and was unable to
influence the american policy toward
iran
because it had so identified with the
republicans but now
lepid who's the foreign minister
and and bennett they're going to be able
to have more influence on the biden
administration because they're not going
to be as hostile
to the to the administration to the
administration's iran policy and they're
going to find those areas of overlap
between the israeli interest and the
and the american interests and very much
taking at face value
the statements of the biden
administration when it says it's going
to prevent iran from getting a nuclear
weapon
and it's going to uh and it's going to
contain iran on the uh on the ground
uh but the the administration is never
going to prevent
um iran from getting a nuclear weapon
for the reasons i said because of the
sunset
agreements the biden administration says
no we're going to get a longer and
stronger agreement so first we're going
to go back to the jcpoa
and then we're going to negotiate with
the iranians for a longer and stronger
agreement
that's like me telling you you put your
house up for sale for
at 500 000 and i i
i buy your house and we close the deal
and then i say now i want to negotiate
with you
further um no i'm saying i did it wrong
didn't i
uh you uh you come and buy
my house for 500 000 and you you buy it
we end the sale and then i come to you
and i say
no actually i want to i want to
negotiate some more and i want you to
pay me another 500 000
and you'll say no i've already done the
deal why should i do that
that's basically what longer and
stronger means because the the jcpoa
hands the iranians everything they want
and gives it to them with an
international seal of approval ends all
sanctions
permanently there's no way to go to the
iranians after you've done that and say
okay
let's negotiate a longer and stronger
agreement well you will accept new
restrictions on your
on your nuclear program it's simply a
slogan
the biden administration is flashing in
the eyes of people who either are not
following closely
or or who are not
willing to admit what they're really
what they're really up to
unfortunately in the case of muhammad
bin salman in saudi arabia
i think he understands this perfectly
and he's saying uh
that you know we we we love iran we want
to see a successful iran and so on
because
it's the price of maintaining decent
relations with washington but he knows
it's a lot of bunk
in the case of the in in the case of the
israeli left that's taken over
i'm not actually convinced that they
understand that the nonsense that
they're speaking
um and that's because they as happened
in our politics where
uh where uh everything became about
donald trump
so every problem you know your position
on everything had to do with your
position on trump
the same kind of thing happened in
israel over netanyahu
uh and so if there if there's a problem
in u.s
iran u.s israeli relations a
disagreement well then it's because of
netanyahu so
now that netanyahu's gone we can get
over this problem with the americans
but the israeli position and the amer
and the biden position there's an
inherent
friction contradiction between them
and i don't think that they ultimately
are going to be able to settle this
they may they may think they have for a
while but that this is going to
be a recurring problem because the
iranians are
right on the ira the israeli border in
syria
they're building their militias there
they're transferring to the malicious
precision guided weaponry
which the israelis understand is
directed at them they're going to take
actions to do something about that
that there's no way the biden
administration can make that go away
simply by making saying nice things
about
iran similarly i think the israeli elite
security establishment understands what
a threat to israel the iranian nuclear
program
is and over time it's going to see
clearly that there is no longer and
stronger agreement
so that friction between israel and the
biden administration is going to
re-emerge
and it's going to be significant it's
something for us to to
watch um a couple i'll just say a couple
more words about
the the um us
uh iranian relations specifically and
then we can open it up for
for wider discussion i think that we are
similarly going to see increased
friction
between the biden administer the biden
administration and iran
over time simply because
i believe as i said at the outset that
my view that is the republican view of
iran
is the correct view i do think it is
hell-bent on
on domination of the entire middle east
i think it is hell-bent on a nuclear
weapon
and i think it is hell-bent on
undermining america's allies
in the region now we may see moments
when it appears that that's not the case
for example you might say to me right
now
well
why why is it why is it that we haven't
seen
greater friction between the united
states and uh and the iranian proxies in
in
in in iraq there's been some friction
yes but how come
how come there isn't greater friction
and i would say that it's just a
question of the moment uh
right now with the negotiations over the
the nuclear question
the the the u.s and iran may come to an
agreement
about the uh about the jcpoa
or they may or they may not they may
come to an interim agreement
and there'll be a little bit of good
feeling for a few months but then some
of these old
some of these old tensions are going to
uh are going to re-emerge i just don't
think this accommodation that they
believe
is out there is going to is going to
is going to actually manifest itself
and the administration is going to have
to
come up with answers to the problems
to the problems that arise it's going to
have to come up with answers to the
problems that
the threat to the direct threat to saudi
arabia
that that iran represents from yemen
and from other areas and it's going to
have to come up with the answers to the
growing cooperation
between between china and iran and
between
russia and iran this is another area
where i think that they have
completely uh misread the map
secretary of state blinken said when he
was in anchorage meeting with his
chinese counterpart that chinese
interests in iran and american interests
in iran are virtually the same
i think this is completely false i think
iran china is
surreptitiously working to help build up
iran in order in order to support it
against the united states
and also in order to exploit the
tensions that the united states has
created with its ally saudi arabia
increasingly if you're saudi arabia and
you see iran
growing in strength you realize that the
only party who can help you on the world
stage
is china or one of the major parties who
can help you is china
and not the united states the chinese
understand this they build up
iran over here and they push saudi
arabia toward them
in this direction these problems whether
whether the administration has the
proper conception
in which to analyze these problems or
not
the problems are not going to go away
and there's going to be
friction with iran directly there's
going to be friction between the united
states and its
uh and and its allies the administration
may not ever come around
to a complete understanding of why that
is the case
but it will not be it will not be able
to sort of
move on to this new stage of of um
uh accommodation with iran and uh
that would that would accommodate with
iran that would allow it to pull back
from the middle east as it as it wants
to
um one last point here and that is
to what matt uh alluded at the
in the in the introduction
even as it sees even as it sees that its
concepts don't fit reality
i don't think the administration can
adjust the concepts
because the concepts are as much
domestic
politics domestic political concepts
as they are foreign policy concepts
and this is one of the things i think we
need to focus on
much more intently the story the
administration is
telling itself and telling its per
especially its progressive base
about the problems of the middle east
is one that is tailor-made to appeal to
progressives
it says that it says that the conflict
that we're having with iran
is the result of our ally israel
our ally israel's aggressive attitude
toward iran is propelling us into a
conflict
that is against our against our own
interests
this plays extremely well in a in a
progressive
to a progressive base which doesn't like
israel
and which has always resented the close
relationship between the united states
and israel
but not just israel also saudi arabia so
those actors on the stage in the middle
east that's benjamin netanyahu and
mohammed bin salman who are actors whom
the progressives are
already predisposed to hate are
are um to the progressives with their
this policy gives the progressives new
reasons
to hate the people they hated already
and
and it turns america and oh not just
not just the people on the international
stage but also the domestic
constituents for the
republican foreign policy whom the
progressives revile
they are also seen as part of the
problem so evangelicals
uh neoconservative republicans are just
republicans who want a muscular foreign
policy or republicans in general
their warmongering in concert with the
warmongering of netanyahu and mohammed
bin salman they're the ones that have
caused the problems in the middle east
and not the iranians so it sets up this
cosmology where america and its allies
are the party
of war or the republicans i should say
pardon me the republicans and their
and america's traditional allies are the
party of war
and iran is the party not so much of
peace but the object of diplomacy
so it's in the diplomacy camp and that
america's
traditional allies are in the war camp
and this is
tailor-made for a progressive
a progressive audience and it it's that
it's that domestic political context the
progressive context of this policy
that's going to make it very hard for
the administration to actually develop
more healthy concepts that will allow it
to read what's actually going on
on the ground so i think we're in for a
lot of friction
and it's our job i say our job because
i'm just assuming
perhaps incorrectly that you're all
largely in agreement with me
i don't know but for those of you who
are agreement in agreement with me
it's our job to watch as these frictions
develop
and continue and to point out to the
american electorate in general
what's going on and why the
administration isn't handling it
correctly
thank you
[Applause]
should should i field the questions then
we've got some time for questions but
you have to wait for the microphone
because we're recording it so
two microphones roaming around here just
raise your hand in between questions
having read your book on ike it seems
like in some ways
i did not plant this it seems like in
some ways we're just repeating history
as a sort of a long-term unreliable and
inept ally
so this gentleman i have no idea who he
is
but he is now one of my favorite people
uh
i i wrote i wrote a book on eisenhower
which is available at bookstores
everywhere
on amazon and
it told the story i actually uh
i wrote it during the obama
administration
and i started writing it really just as
a
as a history and
but as i was writing it i realized that
that it was a
historical argument that resonated with
the
contemporary events i tried not to push
that
too hard actually because
i thought if i turned it into a uh
you know into a policy a contemporary
policy argument i would do damage
to what i thought was a serious
historical argument so i kind of just
hinted at it at the end but i do think
it's
the same thing the the the story i told
there without
boring all of you well it won't bore you
it's a scintillating read actually
i so i don't so that i don't ruin the
book for you i'll just
say very uh uh very quickly
eisenhower tried to stabilize the middle
east in the 1950s by
distancing the united states from israel
and britain at the time
and tried to turn nasser of egypt who
was the soviet union's ally into the
partner
of the united states eisenhower uh
who was an extremely intelligent and
experienced guy in foreign policy
unlike barack obama he was handed this
he was handed this um
strategy by the ex by the middle east
experts
he tried it he recognized it didn't work
and he shifted his concepts that's what
i argue in the
uh in the book he wasn't saddled by any
of the
eisenhower was a realist through and
through and he tried things when they
didn't work he
went on to new to new ideas he wasn't an
ideologue which is what i think the
people ruling this country now
are and i think they have slotted the
iran question
into their into their ideology but
they're drawing on
they are drawing on
undercurrents in our culture which have
been there for a long time there
there is a um i won't i won't
uh i won't go on and on about this but
the the key issue is israel and there
has been a current in our culture
for the last 100 150 years if not longer
where part of our some people in our
culture
see um israel and the jews as
uh if not natural allies i mean
actually kind of extensions of america
uh and then there are the people who see
them as the opposite
and so uh if i could um
and that that has the the political
groupings that have associated
themselves
with the israel is an
asset to america as opposed to there's a
there's a group that sees
israel as a liability the political
groupings have shifted over time when
in eisenhower's day it was a it was a
rockefeller republicans who saw israel
as the great liability
um and republicans in general were much
more
were much more wary of of israel than
were were democrats
over time that cultural current has
shifted and it's now
it's now associated with the
progressives more than any other group
although you still have
some establishment republican types that
that
especially um some of the older uh
people who
who who kind of grew up in that
eisenhower and that
rockefeller republicanism who have that
who have that view that's why it's not
clearly the republican or the
the democratic view um i
i think this is a fascinating subject
and i've actually written some other
things about it i'll if you don't mind
me being self-referential
there's an article i wrote in first
things magazine called
um i don't remember what it's called
if you own first things and you put
duran in there
the field something like the theology of
american foreign policy that this is
this is a i discuss this in there thank
you for raising that
uh yes sir my name is kami but i'm with
the pakistani spectator
and my question is would you call obama
and
trump both successful in their foreign
policies toward middle east because
despite uh bibinahu's best effort to
push america
against iran and start some kind of
trouble with iran
both of them were very successful not to
have
serious armed conflict with iran and
about your republican versus democrat
being a sunni muslim i shouldn't say
this but this is fact
historical fact that while so many
muslims have been crazy they've been
fighting
war from the beginning the jews with
christian you know right and left
but given that iran never attacked any
country
don't you think that both again trump
and obama were realistic
that instead of fighting with iran and
attacking them
we should try to bring closer to america
because
it's given that iranians are a lot more
cultured
than middle eastern uh you know even
though they are muslim but their muslim
identity is not as strong
as their iranian or personal identity so
to me
it's best for america to reconcile their
difference with iran
rather than you know going to
bibinating policy and attacking iran
so what do you think about this approach
making some
peace with iran rather than you know
attacking them
so you and i are in different schools of
thought on this
uh uh i i think that
um obama's policy toward iran
was very unsuccessful uh because i think
he basically handed iran
a very a pathway to a nuclear weapon and
i think that
iran i don't agree with you when you say
iran has never
attacked another country that's a
that's a iranian line of uh it's a line
of iranian propaganda
which has a kind of surface truth to it
because iran has a very weak regular
army
but iran has the revolutionary guards
and it reaches into
uh it reaches into neighboring countries
and it builds up these militias
um hezbollah in lebanon um
and any number of different militias in
in
in iraq and syria and the houthis in
in yemen and i would put you know
in syria 500 000 people
have been killed over 10 million have
been driven from their homes
could be even larger numbers than that
i would blame iran uh first and foremost
for that i mean the iranian method
uh of the iranian method of
uh of fighting the adversaries of the
assad regime is the iranian russian
method of fighting adversaries of the
assad regime
is to drop barrel bombs on civilians who
are going to bakeries
and to drop barrel bombs on um
on on hospitals so i think that
the the amount of just horrendous
killing that has been done in syria is
largely the result of the iranians so
when i hear
you say they have never attacked anyone
i just don't
i don't see it as true at all um
uh i think trump's policy toward
uh toward iran was
not completely successful but i think it
pointed the direction
towards success maximum pressure
that is massive economic sanctions
combined with uh combined with
clandestine covert efforts to sabotage
the nuclear program carried out
primarily by the israelis i suspect it
may be
the americans that hand in it too who
knows combined with
efforts to support allies to stop iran
iranian forces on the ground uh was
a was not completely successful but it
was only in place
in that form in all of those things
combined for about 18 months
so if we had another i mean we shut down
we the united states we shut basically
shut down the iranian economy
and the obama administration told us
that if we did that if we took such
actions there would be war
and not just war it would be war like
george w bush's invasion of iraq
that was totally disproved by uh by uh
by donald trump so i agree with you
trump was successful in that he avoided
war with iran and at the same time he
degraded iranian capabilities
significantly i wish he'd had four more
years to degrade them even more
the iranians are very good the iran the
islamic republic of iran
is like a puffer fish it is
it's not that dangerous but but
it's able to make itself look very
fearsome
and it has developed certain techniques
like with the revolutionary guard of
building up these militias and so forth
um that that make it look stronger than
than it is uh you know donald trump
killed cosmani that's the number two guy
in the iranian regime on the org chart
he's not number two but he was actually
the second most powerful person
in in iran iran couldn't do anything
about it
yes they made a show of fighting back
against us but they but really
they were deterred militarily
uh donald trump shut down their oil
exports
basically brought the country to the
country's economy to a grinding halt
they couldn't do a thing about it
because donald trump understood it's
actually a
a relatively weak third world country
it's not
in middle eastern terms it's a very
significant country 80 million people
it's it's stable and so on but
the united states is a superpower and so
he understood the basic power
differential and he set up a policy that
allowed us to
uh to put pressure uh to put pressure on
it a policy that disproved
all of the claims of the obama
administration
about it so i think that was the that
was the way to go
the the obama the obama administration
the biden's administration has come back
and it's repeating all of the
claims that the obama administration
made in 2015
as if we didn't have this example in
front of us and i've already gone on a
rant here i'll just add one more thing
he also trump also added another element
here which was the abraham accords and
he showed that you could move forward
in um israeli arab peace in ways other
than the power
than going through the
palestinian-israeli bilateral
negotiations
um and and that was a step toward
saudi israeli uh if not peace at least
understanding that's very valuable for
relations between
the united states and the muslim world
jews in the muslim world the united
states the muslim world the west and the
muslim world
and dubai demonstration has turned its
back on that
and it's building up iran which is
rapacious abroad
the iranian regime which is a patience
abroad
and completely illegitimate at home
except
the legitimacy it gets through
threatening people with death
so it makes no sense to me whatsoever
[Applause]
uh eric bordenkirche ucla mike what is
the
or what do you think the play for the
bright administration should be
if this these negotiations in vienna
fall apart or the iranians decide
they don't want to get back into the
agreement and and just another thing too
and i've been very surprised about this
and the body administration has been
rather mum
about it is this issue of nuclear
proliferation in the region
and that the saudis are quite intent on
pursuing those pursuing that agenda if
the iranians do get the bomb
which i think would further destabilize
the region
so uh thanks hello eric i know eric from
twitter
i've never met him in person uh the um
with regard to your your second uh
question or your
or your comment the u.s policy before
obama was to deny
uh countries the complete fuel cycle uh
that was our non-proliferation policy um
and and it was just assumed by the
entire non-proliferation community that
that if iran got the complete fuel cycle
which the jcpoa hands it
that that would lead to a cascade of
proliferation in the region
i see no reason to i see no reason to
doubt that thinking
that was just the assumption of everyone
prior to obama it's widely assumed
correctly or incorrectly i don't know
but widely assumed that saudi arabia has
a nuclear weapon in
escrow and pakistan and the minute
that it has played a role in financing
the pakistani nuclear
program and that the minute iran gets a
bomb
saudi arabia will will import one from
pakistan
the turks are similar to japan and that
they have a modern industrial economy
and
all of the capability they need you're
sort of a one turn of the key away from
developing their own nuclear weapon i
don't know i'm not an expert on these
questions i don't know
how true that is are the turks are the
turks once they make the decision are
they one year from a nuclear bomb or is
it five years whatever it is
given the nature of their uh of their
economy and their scientific community
and uh and their their national
capabilities i'm sure it's not very long
and so the minute the iranian's going to
bomb that the saudis will get one the
turks will get one the egyptians will
want one
and then we'll have a multilateral
nuclear standoff in the middle east
which is a very ugly thought to think
to think about um eric i forgot what
your first question was
what's the party administration's plan
oh
what they're gonna do they they may not
get
they may not get a jcp a return to the
jcpoa
they thought that when they came into
power
and they turned to the iranians and said
let's go back to the jcpoa
they thought the jcp the iranians would
be crazy not to do it and that we'd
be there in a flash uh but the iranians
being iranians they're they're very good
at negotiating and they
they they they sensed the deep desire
of the uh biden administration to return
to the jcpoa so they said
no no no no like you know a blushing
bride no
i don't know whether
whether it's just pure theater and or
negotiation to see how much
concessions they can rent from the
americans
or whether they have made a strategic
decision not to go back to the jcpoa
i don't i do not know uh
the bite and play what it what its play
should be
would be to go to trump maximum pressure
it won't do that
for all the reasons i said what it will
do
is it will uh it will develop
a jcpoa process
like like the like the
israeli-palestinian peace process
the the democrats are very good at this
whenever there's an intractable
attract intractable problem a problem
that can't be solved you set up a
process and you have lots of discussions
about it so they'll
what they'll do is they'll come to some
kind of some kind of
shaky arrangement with the iranians
where okay we recognize that you're
going to keep
the iranians are insisting to keep
certain advanced centrifuges that are
not permitted by the jcpoa
so the the by administration will say
with a wink and a knot okay you can
continue to run those advanced
centrifuges
but keep your stock piles at this level
and then we will lift
sanctions sort of kind of on these
entities
you know and it'll be this hazy
understanding that none of us can quite
uh that that is understood among the
people who are doing the negotiations
and those of us outside don't really
understand and when we do
understand and we say aha this is what
you've done they'll say no we're not
doing that what are you talking about
you know we're
we're trying to contain them and and
they'll turn the fact that they have not
gotten an agreement
with the iranians into a sign that
they're actually being really tough
with the iranians but they're not okay
for one
about two years ago i keep on seeing
a flip-flop strategy
from the american administration
sabotage
just be covered oh i keep on seeing a
good fox strategy from the american
administration towards the syrian
situation and the people that are paying
the price for this
are the formula people are now living
intent to stay awake until
the morning so they just take spiders
off their children before they get
bitten
and i keep on seeing iran expanding and
moving forward
and making influences and making plans
to stay in syria
whereas it's supposed to be leaving
syria and russia
is supposed to be reserved and what i'm
seeing is that
white administration is using us the
syrian people
as a negotiation so in
the name of my people what should we do
oh uh well i sympathize i don't know
that i can answer for you
in the name of your people
i i do think it is um
it is a sad fact
that the united states
in general has never really had a syria
policy
and i i i would say that that was true
even when i was
irresponsible for syria in the white
house i hate to admit that
um it's always been a our
syria policy has always been a function
of our
iran policy so we're we're
we're more inclined but there's always a
hesitancy to get involved in syria
even even before even when it wasn't
military involvement like when i was in
the white house
uh which was 2005-7 but we're more
inclined to contain assad and to contain
the iranians and the russians in syria
when we're when we have a strong iran
containment policy
and when we when we don't uh when we
have an iran accommodation policy then
it's accommodate them
in um in syria i mean i i assume you
know this really quite well
and i don't have a good answer for you
except that we should have a strong
containment policy
sorry i can't solve the problem for you
[Applause]